[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Maryland Wilkes your host and our guest
is Veronica wawoo a visiting scholar in
the Council on African Studies at the
macmillan center she is an
archaeological anthropologist whose
research interests cover prehistoric
technological change and innovation in
our species Homo sapiens her work
focuses on prehistoric projectile
weaponry from the kenya highlands and
the latter Pleistocene her work was
featured in the PBS documentaries the
human spark her current project focuses
on the use of poison assistant hunting
using projectile technology by early
humans today we'll talk with Professor
wallaroo about her current project in
Japan Kenya welcome to such a low level
thank you so let's start with the site
what drew you to it I heard about this
site from my colleagues in the narrow
the museum and we're not exactly sure
what was going on if farmer had called
him in and saved there's some funny
looking works here can you come over and
they get a lot of this report so usually
don't get too excited until you out
there they when they check the place out
and they found out that it was a sight
and but they did not have somebody who
works in there all done with old
archaeological material so when I was
there I said can I come along and
deciduous men so we went up there and he
turned out to be a very very exciting
site okay and how long ago was this when
the first discovery was made and this I
believe was made in april of last eat
okay so fairly recent Eloise okay so the
work you're doing also there is is not
the traditional kind of work how is it
different from other work that's been
done right now we haven't code unload
work but the way we've started it it's
going to be both traditional and
non-traditional ok because about the
non-traditional and let me explain the
tradition of okay I good yes so the
traditional aspect is just the usual you
know scientific investigations when you
go out there you use the same procedures
that other archaeologists are using and
I'm playing what those are two minutes
I'd love to hear about what exactly you
do so you go out of the site you try and
figure out what's going on and you look
at the surface finds the surface
indicators and you're going to find you
know chips of rocks and you have to seek
out in this ad will be made by humans in
the past and once you figure that out
you also want to find out you know what
else is in the surrounding area if you
want to determine how far the site
extent and you want to figure out if
it's being disturbed weather by erosion
or cultivation before you can determine
if it's you know what s kabiri because
you can find a lot of you know very
interesting things on the surface in
terms of you know cultural remains and
but if they've been disturbed for
example by planning then their context
is really disturbed in its not very
useful really so they might be disturbed
on the surface but if you excavated you
wouldn't find anything necessarily so
that's the other thing you have to
figure out how how much is the distance
is it is 57 actually its extensive then
you probably want to think about you
know the exhibition and but once you
determine the days days the possibility
of finding more artifacts you never know
what you're going to find that's redic
reading federal archaeology you can have
the best plans and you know think this
big escalation trench and then and
finding nothing because whatever there
was there was on yet very small lens on
the surface so you have to set out a
test trench and then in this trench
you're going to figure out what license
in it okay but it's usually very
fascinating because you can be around
for a couple of weeks looking for all
great things that I've found on circuits
and don't find them and then just in the
last day when you have to go back
you you know hit the jackpot Wow yeah
and then you have to close shotgun oh
really yeah do you have to yeah because
usually running on turntables and these
tentacles they are determined by you
have to come back to you job at the end
of summer or your funding ran out of the
grain have come the seasons have changed
yes so then what happens to that site
how long does it go without any work
being done or do you call an other
archaeologists from you know perhaps
other places usually this investigations
require a lot of expert and so you
usually you have a team and you're going
to have a paleontology somebody who
studies wrong you may make somebody who
studies pants you may need a geologist
if you're not you know very good in
geology yourself and so it's usually
teamwork and so what usually happens is
that people go they all the sauna or the
link it works and you come in as a team
yeah but I'm so you to go back to unity
institutions try and find funding and go
back again and a lot of these conditions
have been over multiple seasons okay so
how long have you been out there at that
site and I was there for a couple of
weeks I'm not very long and but we do
plan and go yeah I cannot wait to go
back so let's talk about some of the
non-traditional work that you're doing
there it's non-traditional and in this
sense that we involving the local people
not in the at risk evasion but in in two
ways we we get their help in trying to
understand what's happening around the
landscape they know these landscapes
extremely well so for example when I
would I was at this site I looking at
you know the different types of in a
rock that I know ancient people are
using to make artifacts and I'm thinking
you know this could be locker because
they're using a little bit they're not
moving it from very far and so I talked
to a local person and I mean is there
anything that looks like this nearby and
you know we work you know down here a
mile and the quarry this is huge quarry
which I'll probably never have thought
to look and you know they also very
they're very curious and we are you know
they are asking about you know these
artifacts who made them and what they
the math by the Mafia this you know
actually it's ingenious and why they
know ancient mastery and we tell them
talking they were must die but they are
up there definitely your ancestors from
a very modest time period so it's really
the involvement of the community in
understanding the landscape but also the
other aspect that you know this is you
know country material that is found in
the backyard from their lands and you
know property and what has happened
before is rude hire a few local people
to help in the sky visions and feeding
of the soil and probably as a local
guide and to help us intense negotiation
or local politics but we really did not
involve them in trying to tell them you
know this is what thing if things are
and this this is you know volcanic glass
and somebody brought it in from 35 miles
away and it's been kind of sad because
the very easily is it from you know this
country material that is really part of
the Heritage I mean if the heritage of
all humanity bit and given that it's
Africa is a cradle of humanity but i am
the extremely limited from this visit it
now you're bringing a man and kind of
involving them and keeping them posted
on what's going on yes and there is
always the worry that if we ever involve
them they might come back and try and
ask a bit decide and i'll try and pick
up the material but from my experience
when we leave site alone previously a
municipal nodes in there with our track
then our fancy equipment and they
usually leave the site alone and if you
can explain to them especially using you
know the local elders and that you know
don't touch this material just know you
get alone if you catch it then the
contact is lost and it's useless and
then for the most part they're in they
will leave it alone but what I find out
about their definitely curious and
interested and if not really fair to you
know kind of alienate them time to
understand all of this fun very
interesting and history prehistory okay
so what are some of the things you have
found at this point I
so what was really exciting about this
site is we are finding hand action you
know I really obviously finding this in
a strong tool that I just about the size
of my thumb at the bottom and this is
about a sequence about in 35 fields of
pettiness and at the bottom will find
hand axes and basically research that
this go back for you know maybe as far
back as 200 thousand years and then at
the very top we find anything that about
you know an inch you know arrowheads or
pointers we call them in African
archaeology and this is a really very
nice sequence you know that shows that
you know the progression of technology
of a you know very very long periods of
time and it's what is also very
interesting as you can see them using
local materials and then with kinda
start importing more exotic material
that has you know better you know and
properties a device okay we Cal far away
and right now we're not quite sure
that's one of the things that we really
have to find out but with you know given
my prior experience you know with stone
tools and especially the material that i
use in this area they you know they
could be as far as we know 35 40
kilometers from the site and so maybe
they could be further away if you look
at them visually can see it's black
volcanic rock and but if you look at the
edges you can tell from different
sources one is kind of british and this
one that is going to pay explain and
then this one it's all black but you can
see that when you start using this
volcanic glass it gives you a very nice
cutting edge and they miss you and
volcanic glass they are using this altar
call obsidian if it's got all this
inclusions it's not very good quality
and then as you move further to the top
two more recent tachyon times you see
that they're getting very good quality
of brilliance and so they must be
getting it from fire probably trading it
in or traveling further out to find
material that is you know and gives you
a better working it so has this helps
your research at all in terms of the
projectile weapon ray and it's going to
be good because if i can actually
and the arrowheads at the point that we
are finding close to the surface it's
going to give me an idea of you know
when these people probably started using
and you know the ridiculousness and then
i can compare you know how that has
changed because what's great about this
site is and we rarely ever find in our
nice sequence it shows you all these
changes may not necessarily be exactly
the same people maybe the site was you
know occupied organ of a very different
social groups different times and you
can see evidence of volcanic eruptions
very turbulent geological times but you
can really see how that technology
progress right now we take technology
for granted you know have my iphone 5 6
is coming out at me seven is can be hard
but you know in past times you know
those changes were slow and painful but
when they happen they did make a
significant impact in in terms of the
survival of all the people that came up
the technologists I mean that in itself
is very interesting how technology did
change over time and is there any way to
know why that happened and I would be
imagined that it had some adaptive value
and we really do not adopt new
technology really doesn't have any value
to to a life it doesn't make your life
easy but having you know that technology
is great so it won't we'll go back to
about 3.3 million years and again this
is from Kenya but not from this
particular locality and if you can
imagine you know your life without
anything any cutting increment week of
your nails in patience you know as you
say I'm like really pretty difficult we
can all roll and for granted but just
having that fast cutting edge what was
great in itself I'm so imagine having
you know a a projector and weaponry
where you can put distance between
yourselves and something pretty hunting
something they will probably fight back
or something advanced very quickly that
does give you some advantage and and it
it saves you from injury if you're
injured you're not and you're not very
helpful to you society
and then if you have to just if you're
using a sphere and you have two choices
I name all over the place if you get
tired you use a lot of colors and you
want to maximize the amount of color
images get from the many more compared
to how much Kyle little color is you
know you extend it with chasing that
animal so if you can think the color is
great you can apply this color is to
admin reproduction and other things so
we're humming Homo sapiens at that point
using fire how did that come later much
earlier I'm based and you know and find
from other sites in a fire has been
around for a long time so they
definitely had friends they definitely
hot right sometimes you know I think
what it would be like to have to have
been that first person way back event if
you have you know said hey you know
let's cut this stone to make this weapon
I mean isn't that a fascinating thought
for I mean especially for you to think
who would be announced that very first
person to make that technological change
it is fascinating and when I'm talking
to the local people I try and you tell
them just in a cannula can you imagine
being able to make something like this
and using it to me to cut up in all
things or are we just using and you know
a blade from the you know from the
stones even push up an animal in it
Julie we do this experience with
students in in the beginning they're
incredibly like this is not going to
work and once they've done it daily well
you can actually do that on tools and it
makes a huge difference so um it is very
exciting and it's even more exciting
when you first is find something that
has not been found out there but it's
just a one or two pieces and you're
linking if you can accident there is
going to be a trend and that's why I'm f
covering this site is important because
site the date back to that transition
and where you actually get Homo sapiens
appear and then the technology that
comes comes with that and our prayer the
extreme is where and so whatever we have
to say about this plan period is based
on just going to find from a few sites
and you know if
the current and knowledge is for most of
the time we be facing the necklace
generalization justice and a few sites
and then little on you find more sites
and then we have to change what you said
before there's always better when you
have more data from most likely to get
it yes oh you are your are you
collaborating with other archaeologists
at other sites to kind of help advance
the knowledge of that time period and
right now we I'm working with the team
from at the Museum and we will
definitely bring more people on board
once we you know we open up a large
exhibition and it always makes sense to
me to cooperate with people from even
from different different and so we will
compare what we find with what has been
found other other side from dating
through this Center they're not that
many but we'll definitely doing that and
are they all in Africa yes for the most
states are going to be studying to be an
Africa I'm wondering you know what it
will actually take to know how far back
humans you know walk plan for instance
what their environment was like was
their environment you know similar to
what it was is today or was it vastly
different and also you know how they
lived and that's a good question because
that the local people were also asking
me the same so the first thing you do is
you are going to once you ask a date and
the site you you dated you use as a
carbon dating is that what its father
this is going to be beyond you know the
limits of carbon dating I suspect it's
going to be on carbon dating right now
has a limit of us you know fifty sixty
thousand luck and a suspect this is
going to be older than that but we're
very lucky in the sense that we have a
you know this old surfaces that people
lived on and covered by you know
volcanic ashes so it would be living on
that you know in the surface and they've
been dropping their you know their
weapons and some a broken window making
someone defense I understand in the site
and then some eruption would happen and
at that side will signal that status
would be completely filled and then the
pentacle different group of people to
come by
and then do the same thing and another
action happens indeed I was thinking
about it just you know how the life of
the seeker my self diagnose it is very
turbulent geological episodes and so
that's great for us because this life is
filled and a volcanic eruption is and it
happened to be in a fairly short time
for you can get that event and so we're
going to be using the volcanic ashes to
identify and once we figure that out we
can correlate that data to and global
climate what was going on at that point
you know globally with it you know it's
not in hemisphere covered in glaciers
and that would you know like a global
cold period and all will be the one
period and then locally and you can also
find within the state the soil you can
not be ashes but you know these files
you can find plans remain you can find
plant vitally and we can say hey they
have those trees and grasses here those
grasses and if you are very lucky we
find your name is opening small mammals
person and that we may also find things
like snails that tell you all this was
right environment yes they use a lot of
proxy data to try and figure out you
know the you know the global climate at
that time and then we look from those
local indicators of specific
environmental defense was there anything
that was particularly surprising to you
while you're while you're working at the
site and what was really intriguing was
just why was this place occupied over
and over and over again that works
levels that is you know something that
is serious and it's great for us and of
course we have to set on you know
wondering did they leave here today you
live someplace else and talking to the
local people there's a soldier and told
us what anybody lips and caves near the
river like case why didn't you tell me
okay so yeah so he walked out you know
about two miles cross the river and you
wasn't exactly k because the rock
shelter this for
overhand and like it maybe they live
here and because you found other sites
that were also in a bounded in of such
rock shelters so we plan on involving
more people and scientists and in local
and hopefully we can get a clear picture
of what is going on interface so moving
forward when you go back to the site
ultimately what would be something that
you would really love to find there i
would like to i would love to find some
what we really hope for is a good sample
size you know going down to know too
they're all the clay of that site that
that transition period when you had you
know tools that you know we can
associate with homo sapien see in a
previous tools or they need their
depositions and kind of hominids and
probably homo erectus and that would
like to find right now we have you know
we have a few hand accrued that would
hope for you know a bigger sample size
so that we know that you know we can
actually convince people before going on
yes okay this isn't fascinating for me
thank you so much for being here today
it was ok for more information about
professor wawoo and her work please
visit our website at macmillan report
that yale edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the whitney embedding mcmillan
Center for International in theory study
[Music]